you shame your mustard that looks like
lots of little pebbles sort of we had it
at lunch today
it was literally at lunch today Kelsey I
like ketchup
obviously sweet comforting reliable
complex varied challenging can you love
them both of course you can but maybe
one's better than the other
ketchup versus mustard it's debatable
I am 100% team ketchup team mustard
ketchup
I am from mustard my allegiance lies
with ketchup hi I'm Keith and I'm not an
idiot
you grow up with ketchup we don't really
grow up with mustard like mustard is
kind of more of an acquired taste than
ketchup yeah
all the best tastes are acquired taste
this is from food historian Andrew F
Smith ketchup is a perfect balance of
the five fundamental tastes salty sweet
sour bitter and umami your products
Amami mean umami I'm not sure it's a
food science work you could put it on
anything all kinds of savory things what
can you put mustard on one thing hotdog
first of all you can't put ketchup on
everything you don't put ketchup in
cereal let's just be clear mustard goes
on sandwiches it goes on pastrami it was
some tons of stuff
kids love ketchup here's why ketchup is
for children it helps children eat foods
that they don't like it's just there to
cover up flavors that they haven't
acquired yet without this I wouldn't
have made movies in my backyard when I
was 12 where people died
ketchup looks like but mustard looks
like pus I have a video that's going to
put three million views on YouTube in
which I use mustard to make pus for a
pimple I am a very surprised you at a
counter-argument for that I know what
ketchup is it's a tomato duh [ __ ] is
mustard what is a mustard it's a seed
ketchup is not a category of food
ketchup is just one sad thing that's
consumed by sad people who's eaten more
of their condiment during this battle
I've eaten way more mustard than Chris
has eaten ketchup because I love mustard
and he hates mmm umami I taste the umami
now I know your entire character here at
BuzzFeed is the girl who indulges in
things that's bad for them and I don't
give a [ __ ] it's sort of run its course
I think by now and ketchup is for
children it's what you give children
because it's sugar salt and tomato
delicious things
it's an ancient condiment mustard can be
traced back to ancient Greece to France
I think the Romans invented it are you
sure about that I'm pretty sure you also
ate so much that they would throw up and
then eat again so that's actually a
misconception that's not true hey you
sure yeah I made a video about it oh my
god you know what's not on a charcuterie
tray [ __ ] ketchup because ketchup is
worthless and not worth your expensive
ingredients to do this sounds like
what's nothing where you're racist
towards class classist that sounds like
what mustard
anywhere I once said all cooks are the
same and all cokes are good and that's
kind of how I feel about ketchup yeah he
was all the same if you want to grow up
and enjoy actual flavor there's a yellow
seed out there for you
ketchup is a nostalgic food it's from
when you were a kid so it gives you my
spoon feelings about being a child like
boogers and worms
ketchup is everybody we are I'll catch
up somebody in the comments I'll get it
there got it